every morning chef Pascal bro and his
team arrive at 7:00 a.m. they spend
hours preparing fresh meats vegetables
and sauces from scratch because I said
oh god this is what comes with the
pleasure so this morning we cut about 15
kilos of zucchini in this one hundred
and thirty year old restaurant near the
Paris Stock Exchange everything is
handmade the chef says it for fewer
hours and leave half the staff if these
industrial food I have a hard time
finding real cooks here a cook needs to
know how to make desserts starters
terrines cut the meat cut the vegetables
and cook them but that's not the case in
all French restaurants in a recent
survey one third admitted they use food
made in factories and the proportion
could be much higher one French Member
of Parliament Daniel fat squirrel is
trying to change that his proposal a law
restricting the label restaurant to
those preparing their own food France's
national assembly only agreed to add a
homemade logo but he says that's not
enough we put our whole thing I didn't
smoke well we're like you'll need to
walk into the restaurant open the menu
and only then will you see whether the
dishes are homemade a knife I'd rather
regulate the use of the word restaurant
just like we did for bakeries back in
1998 the word boulangerie was restricted
to bakeries that made their own dough
bistros like lunesta hay wants similar
laws to protect French fine dining to
avoid a brain drain of chefs gotten soft
difficult yet when they leave cooking
school if they find themselves in that
type of industrial restaurants where
they cut plastic bags and put it in the
microwave they lose their motivation so
they quit that job or go abroad the
country of gastronomy is losing its
cooks because in a number of restaurants
you don't cook anymore something hard to
conceive for this chef Tom Gibson
Bloomberg